[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
and a few years ago i lost an enough
weight to like maintain like a just a
healthier yeah look went on a big tour
gained like 25 pounds you're one of
those guys who i think you can pull it
off i think because when you when i saw
your fir one of your first netflix
specials you had a lot more weight on
yeah but you weren't like obese or
anything that you just look like the guy
like i remember watching the special
even though it was already pre-recorded
and i had already met you in real life i
was like i wonder if this guy's dead
right now because he just looked at his
face like oh that guy had to have died
from a massive heart attack you know
yeah
there's no way like i was like thinking
like he's not gonna make it through the
set even
yeah you know yeah but then and then
when i see skinny tom yeah you know it's
like it's like holy [ __ ] this guy's
[ __ ] sexy it's way
it's my uncle he wasn't my dad's brother
but it was like close uncle like i had
an uncle bobby pets who he's a real guy
and he had like all these animals and he
[ __ ] loved animals
when i was a kid when i was kid i was
like oh it's just got like like a little
petting zoo like in his backyard he
always had like a crazy [ __ ] he had like
a penguin i never forget it was like
summer like 1996 in brooklyn guys if
penguin walked i swear it was like it
was like july 4th weekend
well i don't remember how he got it but
i do remember the penguin me and my dad
go into his house bobby pence's house
like the next week
and he had like a like an air
conditioner and two fans on but it was
like you know sweltering new york city
heat and i was like i feel like i was
like 12 at the time you know like all
about like science and all that was like
i don't think like this is mimicking
like antarctic conditions yeah your
frigidaire [ __ ] air conditioner was
just like rattling in a basement and
then he was feeding a cheese and i was
like i swear to god i just feel like
that's not
no yeah it died it died a week later oh
yeah oh my god and then my dad and bobby
pants buried the penguin off the side of
the new jersey turnpike this a lot of
times you're making [ __ ] up i'm not
making it up no you can't it's just true
is there any downside to steroids
because of course i was tempted but and
i knew um a couple guys in high school
and then a couple guys that didn't do it
in high school but they went to college
and you know when you go back
back home you'd see
like
man like dude god
huge but i still never did it but i was
always like you know curious i don't
think that there's actually a downside i
mean i know they say oh if you take hgh
or some types of stories you can get
cancer but it's like dude like you can
get cancer from anything a lot of things
yeah you know vaping everything could
give you cancer i actually think
steroids because i think we're having a
big problem now with entertainment and
sports especially baseball i'm very pro
to just have an all steroid baseball
league it'd be great why throw them out
just have the league my things with
baseball is let's have everybody use
steroids or who wants to and then every
you know inning or or once a game we
give their best hitter in aluminum bat
yeah and you let them just [ __ ] maybe
kill somebody in the infield yeah
because
you know it's drowning but you do fall
in love with men have sex with women
yeah hold on what do you mean you fall
in love like emotionally you're in love
with a man but physically you're into a
woman is that what you mean yeah i think
like i'm not gay right i don't have any
even really gay thoughts like i've never
thought about having sex with a guy but
i have talked to men for a long time
looked in their eyes been fascinated by
their conversation yeah and either went
home and beat off or went home and had
sex with a woman oh wow so i don't know
if what that is where that falls you
think that that's because men are more
interesting and smarter okay okay
yeah
it could be
no women are [ __ ] stupid because
women are [ __ ] dumb no
maybe
yeah
i could i'm so hyped to juice if you
want to get back on a cycle together
i'll do it with you i swear to god dude
i will do [ __ ] i'll do steroids on
the live show you just get me the
syringe and you it could be a mystery
steroid and i'll just [ __ ] light
myself up whatever it is dude was what
was the okay
what was what happened when you stopped
was it a a notable holy [ __ ] drop no you
know what happened when i stopped is i
kind of start to get these things called
brain zaps where like i would be like
you know in school or like playing ball
like you know i played division three
basketball and like my brain would just
go
like that and it would just go like that
and i thought and i was telling
everybody like i got to the point where
i got so nervous that i like told my mom
i got neurological cat scans they
thought maybe i had a brain tumor all
that stuff and my dad finally was like
when are you gonna come clean he's like
you know i'm not gonna [ __ ] rat you
out but when you can come clean and tell
everybody why you get them zaps and i'm
like yeah i don't want to say it i want
to say and then finally i just had to
tell my mom and the doctors like oh i
you know
i know like you don't see anything but
like it could possibly be that i was
using winstrol for two years and just
immediately stopped and the doctor was
like yeah that's it stupid if you would
have told us that six months ago you
wouldn't have done all these scans yeah
you wouldn't have just cost your mother
twenty five thousand dollars in hospital
bills i was like sorry mom
i was like i thought my insurance
covered it
i've been here for three weeks and it's
been unbelievable like i've been jerking
off to anything like everything yeah i
was jerking off to anderson cooper yep
two days ago wow then this morning
tucker carlson yeah all you know they
had an all that's going on and i was
just like and i don't jerk off like this
i rub the base of my penis and i blow it
into my belly button yeah it's a very
strange way of masturbating and i think
that might you rub it against your belly
i kind of rub down i make like a little
vagina with my thumbs and i rub the base
and then i shoot it into my body
seriously i swear to god i gotta tell
you something i mean with that i mean i
don't even know you that well yeah i
would i would like to you to do it to me
yeah and i would dude i absolutely would
that sounds like a really good technique
discover this technique i don't know i
just i i think when i was a kid i just
um you know i kind of i used because i
used to take a pillow i used to like
masturbate on a pillow i slept in the
same room as my mom until i was about 13
14 years old
so i used to like you know when she was
sleeping quietly yeah quietly just take
a pillow i used to do that
started you used to hump the mattress
yes i was having orgasms before i
ejaculated oh me too i was i was
absolutely shooting blanks and i was
like like trying to explain to my cousin
yeah brian i was like do you do that
thing cause i didn't know words for it i
was like you know where like you you you
like you rub yourself a certain way and
your body shakes and it feels good he
was like what yeah and i go you know
what i mean like and then you kind of
sweat a little bit yeah i don't know
what you're talking about well i re
because i would do that so much i would
masturbate so much and just shoot blanks
that the first time i did get just a
little bit of jizz i lived in the same
house as my mom's sister and she used to
watch me well while my mom was at work
and i i was like doing it like rubbing
the pillow hard and then a little
splooch came out and i was young and
inexperienced i didn't know so i ran to
my aunt colleen i was like aunt colleen
something's coming out of my peepee and
she's like an old-school new york lady
smoking a cigarette she's like
christopher listen to me you can have to
talk to your mother about that
[Laughter]
i remember she was blowing the smoke
she's like i can't even deal with this
right now and then i'll never forget
she's like do you want an assault team
cracker
a thousand jump shots a day every day he
would have the broom never tell you
about my dad's broom uh-huh he's gonna
have a broom up because my dad's whole
thing was like you need to you need to
mimic shooting over seven footers like
you need to arc shots so this is i'm
talking about like in a public park in
ridgewood queens which is a very
culturally diverse neighborhood you had
people from all over the room stick up
he had a broomstick up and on the
broomstick written in tape was the word
leroy he named the broom leroy
because he was like let's be honest it's
gonna be a seven foot black guy though
and then so we just call it elite so i
would shoot over leroy and that's what
he said to me when i was in the
windshield like a dead serious
conversation she's like what about all
the times me you and leroy had
in the park you disrespected us all you
know what leroy's pissed dude he made
leroy i've said this too on on a podcast
too but like my dad like in ridgewood
this was like what was called like a
ridgewood coffee like
my dad and his friends would go into
bodegas or coffee shops or whatever and
like let me get a coffee leroy that was
a coffee black with no milk they would
say like let me get a coffee leroy and
then that would just be handed the
coffee like that and i just thought
i was like oh i didn't you know because
growing up with the type of father
trying that at starbucks right yeah can
i get a coffee
what it's totally black yeah a leroy no
ice
you know you thought that was like order
coffee the mo of like almost all
comedians truly is they're just like i
just want you to like me yeah who then i
saw a quote from my favorite comedian
bill cosby and i
i saw a quote from him that said it said
i don't know the secret to success but i
know the secret to failure is trying to
please everyone and i was like wow that
guy's [ __ ] smart knows what's up
but the irony is that his material was
super universal and not inflammatory in
the least i mean his [ __ ] was like you
go dennis
[ __ ] is he talking he's gonna do that
again dude again
he goes
you got the string
i'm like what the [ __ ] yeah talk about
your dick weirdo i don't trust him
comic that doesn't talk about his dick
yes you've been saying that for a decade
but does he have opinions on the vaccine
does he yeah yeah dude my i think my dad
is the leader of q anon
i genuinely believe what does he say
about it okay so my mother got the
vaccination like as soon as she was
eligible she's all about my dad legit my
stepmom because my parents got divorced
my stepmom legitimately was like you you
will not
like be able to like get on a plane and
go see yours because they live in
florida now now my dad lives in tampa
tampa toni he's just following kovak
like wherever the hot spot is let's go
once it started clearing in new york and
florida exploded he was like i'm moving
by the way he didn't even tell me he was
moving to tampa i mean this is my
biological father he moves on july 6th i
call him you know july 7th july 8th you
know just to check in i'm like hey dad
what's up you know you want to get
coffee he's like oh i'm in florida and i
was like okay so when you get back he
goes i'm not coming back i got a house
down here i said wait a second you've
moved
with your wife to florida he goes yeah i
was like i didn't why didn't you tell me
i'm your son he was like i don't know
you were hanging out with your boyfriend
or something and i was like
that's what he said and i was like dad
you're my legit like you're my actual
father dude like well he's like well
come down and visit get on a plane what
are you scared of [ __ ] covid and i
was like i guess not if it got to the
point where he was being so risky
because he would wear the mask on his
ear yeah in march and april he was
wearing the mask on his ear taking the
public transportation the bus in new
york city dangling just dangling and i'm
like dad you have to wear it on your
face he was like i didn't know i had a
gay son that's what he would say when i
would tell him to like put it over his
face and that's everything with him is
that even with the vaccine his i was on
i was literally facetiming with like my
my girlfriend my kids so like whatever
little kids
and my father i'm on the phone my father
and my stepmother and my stepmother says
we got good uh good news chris your dad
finally get this your tab finally got
the second shot and i was like oh
great dad how do you feel he was like
yeah he was like your stepmother said i
couldn't see you unless they lit me up
with the homo juice so i got some and i
was like and then my daughter's like
what did he say i'm like nothing honey
let's go watch puppy dog pals you know
freedom to me now is having just one
option one great relationship with my
daughter's mom the
concept of family building a family
that is like i feel totally free i feel
like i have so much energy here yeah for
the last three weeks because i haven't
act i've been like i'm only waiting for
the call from the one woman and the one
family and that's what it is now my
hotel room walls have gotten [ __ ] lit
up but that my therapist said that's
okay this guy's a [ __ ] loser cut his
mic i know
i know my dad's listening to this like
you [ __ ] hobo
i told you to pounce some ass out dear
chrissy
like he thinks even me doing a podcast
this guy he's like get a little closer
to mike you know you're like
he'll call me and say things like that
[Laughter]
they never call me ever again like yeah
if you if i text them and they'd be like
oh i had a great time but i'm just not
interested anymore it's like we were
fine the addicts were finding each other
yeah kind of wow how do you approach i'm
fascinated like how do you approach the
other one how do you sniff her out like
how do you know who's broken enough to
you know the in opening message on a dm
you know what is
mean really yeah or the opening messages
hey i you know heart eyes or i think
you're hot or take me out for a drink
and i'll give you the night of your life
things like that i was like yes yes
where another girl was like hey do you
want to like take me to dinner i'm like
no come on
can i stick garlic sticks up your [ __ ]
yeah no
you know so i would not i was not
looking and then you know what i
realized too it's just so [ __ ] gay
just play gay porn over this this is
gayer than the guy getting pounded in
his ass but it's just the truth i got a
lululemon pants any guys out there want
to hit me on grindr um
how did it go on him fitness pal it's so
far today it's been so far well listen
it's about 2 10
pst and um i have 20 uh 2100 calories uh
for the day and i'm at 1900. okay so
yeah because my kid wanted to go to ihop
this morning oh that's what happened and
you know what i do though sometimes is i
don't log in stuff and then in my head
i'm like ah it doesn't count right if
you don't log in yeah and so my weight
has stayed relatively the same for the
past three months i think i'm down about
four pounds but i'm putting on a little
bit more muscle because i started to to
hit the gym uh more now and heavy you're
going heavy i'm going heavy and i'm
actively using winstrol which is a
steroid that's it awesome what could you
do did you did you juice as a kid i
juiced as a kid when i was 19. you know
what you look like you juice yeah dude
like like your haircut and your whole
look i'm like this guy's voided out i
don't do well you know what that's the
thing with me is i think i'm just a
misunderstood guy like even now because
it's like you know i have like a
republican haircut but like a democrat
brain you know i got like white skin but
like a black girl's ass right you know
right like i love chinese food but i eat
it with a fork right i mean like [ __ ]
like that yeah i'm like crissy gray
zones i'm all over the place
yeah you know but but i just feel like
you know i when i was using steroids in
in how long were you on them for i was
in steroi so
i was on the basketball team at
archimonde high school shout out um
proud very proud to say that nobody uh
there sexually uh assaulted anybody even
though it was an all boy catholic high
school um a couple of kids committed
suicide which you know i guess i don't
know but maybe they did maybe there's
you know some sexual assault i don't
know about but just shout out um and and
um and uh
when i was using steroids i was about 17
my senior in high school all the way
through 19
uh sophomore year in college when i got
caught with the pack of syringes by my
father and oh he didn't know he didn't
know and my father's only rule only
really rule was you know don't use no
needles
no needles you know he's like you know
you're never going to use heroin you're
not going to use steroids okay you know
and then he re it was actually one of
the only times in my father's whole life
he's ever been like truly upset with me
well he was super pissed he was like
genuinely like disappointed he was like
i thought you were like just this
amazing white kid that was dominating
everybody else but you're on the [ __ ]
juice like he was so angry and i'm like
yeah like i'm i wanted like the
competitive edge and he was like you
played division three basketball like
you're not going anywhere right you know
what i mean like
i can understand if you're juicing
because you you know you're trying to
walk on at north carolina right right
but you genuinely there's a girl on your
team in college and that's a true story
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]